hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game between these two
gentleman a gentleman yesterday we've
checked out a game where Xiang Yu Shu
had the white pieces and the Grisha Quan
a very nice game even though he was lost
at one point but someone is always a
lost at one point and finally it took us
three videos but we finally got the
quote above the board right so now this
is a rematch Xiang Xiang Yu Shu must win
on demand as if he draws or loses the
game he is out of the video World Cup so
let's see what he chooses with black as
a must-win opening Grisha opens with d4
sorry about that with Knight to f6 by
Shu c4 e6 Knight to f3 and of course the
five the Queens gambit the client is on
the board in the g3 agree should prepare
Sofia to the light square bishop and
black does the same with Bishop the
g-tube Bishop to g7 and both players
Castle and here we should just plays b3
you know preparing to think it with the
other Bishop as well because why not
black is playing symmetrically so
there's no need to rush anything with
Knight to c6 Bishop to b2 developing the
the darks worship as well and now there
are a few known moves in this position
like rook to b8 is a normal night each 7
is a known move a 5 is a known move but
b6 the move shoe place is a new move in
this position and this is well perhaps
something he prepared for for today's
game which will give us well for fee and
Karel bishops which is not something you
see very often with Knight bTW 2 and an
out Bush of the b7 and now if you check
out the bishops it's not like super rare
but but it is rare to see them nicely
being kettled like this look the c1
Begley shook putting a rope on a
soon-to-be open C file semi-open so
tonight's the East 7 and here comes
Queen to c2 with rook to c8 black does
the same and rook F to d1 developing the
other look as well black develops the
other rook is well rook to e8 and now
Knight to e5 an excellent square for the
knight that also opens up for this
diagonal now
lack is unable to capture and see for as
the Bushman b7 would hang with Knight to
d7 offering a trade of Bishops here and
here Knight back to d3 judicially
declines with Knight back to f6 and here
Grichuk says to his opponent Knight back
to e5 he says even though it's only
moved 15 and I have the white pieces I
am very satisfied with a draw here
because drawing a game in this position
would assure me to advance in the Phaedo
World Cup 2019 so of course shoe cannot
allow this even though he would not mind
a draw with black against the Grisha but
not in a game that he simply must win so
he plays h5 and now efore by Grisham
with D captures on e4 Knight captures on
e4 Knight captures on e4 Bishop captures
on e4 all the trades are are in well
guru shops favor
Bishop characters on e4 Queen captures
on e4 and now c6 and if you look at this
position it seems like black is
perfectly fine but black doesn't really
have much to show for Queen to f3 now
here gray ship is going after the f7
pawn and black has to defend it now
either black will try something like f6
or or or will he capture the knight on
e5 maybe f6 here was was just a little
bit better as well it's it's hard to say
but you you don't want to trade too many
pieces you have to win this game with
black but ok with Bishop captures on e5
d captures on e5 opening up an attack
against the Queen now and Queen to c7
attacking the e5 pawn and here well not
at the moment as it's protected by the
bishop but you know pressuring it with
h3 and now rook seek to d8 just offering
a trade of rooks and here Rachel goes
for Queen to f6
h3 was a was a very important move
before going Queen to f6 because if he
played it without that then after Queen
f6 you could sort of lock the Queen out
of the game with Knight to f5 this way
by playing gauge 3 first after Queen to
f6 Knight a5 you for example
if we went a knife to f5 here you could
you could push play g4 maybe sort of a
get a funky line let's say g4 h captures
G capture scent now after this night
comes here you will get look to d6 and
it will be just a very nice position
sort of a free root lift as you you're
gonna play rock CD one and the black
cannot capture of course if you captured
then it's a problem
you're either losing the Queen or you're
getting checkmated since the bishop is
also controlling this diagonal so not
Knight to f5 Knight back to c8 and now
comes hook to d6 and Gary shook still
goes for the free rook lift as the idea
is pretty much the same even capturing
with the knight doesn't help you're just
gonna capture and it's still either you
lose the queen or you're getting made it
no no way around that
so after look to b6 we have Queen to e7
offering a queen trade and here
gireesham says okay I don't mind this
very nice trade with Queen captures now
comes Knight captures you can't play
rook captures otherwise you lose the
rook on d8 so Knight captures on e7 and
now rook C to D 1 nicely doubling up
rooks on the D file and now rook to b8
black does not want to trade as you know
trading even more will only bring Grisha
closer to a draw to at least a draw so
Bishop to c1 now transferring the bishop
to this diagonal now we have c5 by black
and Bishop to g5 of course the the rook
is gonna come to d7 that's the idea so
Brooke the b7 are trying to control that
rook and now g4 with rook the see rook
to c7 as black really doesn't have all
that many moves and now rope the d8
threatening to capture the rook here
with rook captures rook captures and now
King - h7 so it's a really passive
position for black not a lot to do but
it's also a losing position for black so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this wonderful winning idea
agree shook found while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent
threatener of mate and h8 and for those
you rhyme was not intended and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy show gosh up
to f6 and now now you either get
checkmated on a check or you go into
sort of a to swan where you just have to
resign and this is in fact what happened
rook the c8 is terrible it seems like
you're preventing roof de [ __ ] and you
are but you're not preventing Bishop
captures 97 so I hope no one was
thinking about the roof to c8 but nice
the g8 this is the only move and here
agree should play the g5 and it was in
this position that young you should
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to do here he can't really move
anything he can just play move that
wastes time the e7 is covered by the
bishop so you can't use that you can go
here the D file is controlled by guru
stroke you can just play rubies and Roxy
some Ruby 7 or c7 repeat moves and
that's pretty much it and the wife will
just get closer and closer with the King
play a 3 B 4 break open on the Queen
side and at one point eater go after the
sea or the beep on the depending where
the black rook will be and of course if
you capture on f6 this does really
change anything just eat captures on f6
and still you don't have any moves you
can just play some moves a 6 a 4 you can
try b5 but let's say a character say
captures white will not capture on b5
just for now the winning idea is a rook
to e8 now you're gonna go rook the e7
and either get a pass born on e7 or for
example capture on f7 and then go after
the Queen side pawns we could imagine
something like a Bishop captures Bishop
captures and rook d7 and after rupee 7
finally comes now you either go rook to
d1 check you cannot trade King G - and
now kink the g8 defending this but now
you're just gonna force the King back
rookie checking if 7 rook c8 white is
much quicker to go after the c5 pawn and
after Luke the c1 rook captures on c5
and with the King being unable to enter
the game via any means you're just gonna
put the rock on c8 push the pawn all the
way to c7 and black will be paralyzed
white will be able to do whatever white
wants yeah and that's
that's what would happen in this case
and well that's if you capture if you
don't capture if anyone is interested
let's say you just repeat moves wrong be
seven Roxy 707 you just bring the teen
into the game
kingi - Roxy seven we're gonna go king
of 3a Ruby seven King III rook c7 king
de rule b7 King to c3 Roxy 7 h 4 you're
just gonna block the position a three
rule goes back to c7 you're gonna play
f3 ruby 7 and now you're gonna push b4
rook back to c7
now you go rook to b8 you take away this
square from the black rook but it
doesn't help you leave him the d7 square
but it's not all that much B captures on
c5 b cap force and rook c8 you're gonna
win this pawn and then it's it's pretty
much the same idea the knight can't move
the King can come into the game and the
black rook is hopeless against all of
White's forces yeah after g5 it was
either I get made it or go into this
wonderful song a good issue created and
well I really enjoyed this game it was a
the game I chose but if you really
enjoyed some of the games then feel free
to use hashtag suggestion for those of
you who were waiting for the England
versus re-raise of Raja I decided not to
show those games as well spoiler alert
both of their classical games were drawn
and they were like really really intense
well not intense but they were like
first game was like a really strong
preparation followed by a draw
and the second game was out really quick
21 move draw wording had the white
pieces think just oh I believe he even
offered the draw maybe but it was a
really quick ride and feel like showing
it and it's gonna be it's gonna be
really awesome as Reza is really well
through Rochas when it comes to rapid
games but being it just knocked out
Magnus Carlsen in in rapid tiebreaks in
the ending fourth cup so it's gonna be
tomorrow we're gonna have some crazy
games between dinghy and a few Raja you
can bet on that
how about yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Dave Pearce ganodi guarana after I did
Kiko and Jim Thompson for a career
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos serie thing go for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
checking up on your suggestions and well
as soon as we get this over with
the conclusion of the capablanca saga so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest today